and I wish we didn't even care about
what we ate you know I think there was a
long time ago probably back in the old
days you know out but now everybody's so
concerned about their diets everybody's
on the diet I'm on this you know I'm on
Atkins I'm on Jerry Atkins you know I'm
I'm a senior you know I'm on keto you
know Mon kato kaelin I'm on you know
only cheeseburgers
during murders you know everybody's on
somethin I'm on vegetables a mom you
know broccolini
you know only only by my stepmothers
house my buddy told me is on that diet
I'm like that's not a [ __ ] diet but
you're gonna you're gonna star if you're
an idiot
but everybody's on some type of diet you
know somebody's like I'm on you know
water and limes like a that's not a diet
you know that's somebody that's you know
probably gonna die on an island you know
so some of this stuff isn't died isn't
diets sorry Isaac call came in and I
have a ringtone of a teenager but yeah
everybody's on a diet everybody's on
something you know and it's just but
back in the old days you didn't you
weren't on a diet if somebody shot an
animal that's what you ate if somebody
killed a um you know a bushel of corn
that's what you ate somebody showed up
with a you know a little bit of Labrador
a couple of Labrador medallions that's
what you ate that was it I mean there
were probably years where people were
eating this or eating that you know I'm
not trying to be viable but people were
you know having German Shepherd for
dinner a long time ago in the 1700s come
on you know people were having haen't
you know a ham was you you kill a pig
and that's that was it somebody shoot a
dove or an owl and that was it
and that's what you ate there wasn't an
opportunity for all this dieting but now
you know once we get you know we get a
little bit more sedentary in that food
starts to build up in us so it's just a
different time now and so now you know
we're a little bit more concerned and we
didn't have mirrors back then that's
another thing maybe instead of diet and
we just get rid of all the mirrors have
we thought about that yet
I mean I sometimes I wish we could just
have a big mirror burning you know
everybody just shows up and throws a
damn mirror into a big gorge one of
these empty gorges and just throws a
bunch of gasoline in there a turpentine
and lights had [ __ ] up let's burn these
mirrors so who knows who's fat who knows
who who's out of shape who knows who's
feeling a little you know if you lift
your arm up and you can't lift it up or
if your underarm just you know I got a
buddy he's got his underarms have kind
of become tits under his own and they
still have all that hair on him that
underarm hair so he'll lift his arm up
and it's like this just hair tit kind of
pops out from under his arm and I don't
know why I don't know what's going on
with him he's like I'm thinking I need a
diet I'm like I think you need a haircut
on them tits first and go from there but
it's you know it's just I before we were
infected with all these diets I think we
used to enjoy our time a little bit more
and I guess if I could look back on
today a little bit I'll probably wish I
would have not thought about you know
calories and all of this and that as
much but I would have just been you know
more focused on you know what's crazy as
my sister can't even read but what does
it have to do with us right now
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one
different options different choices some
guy just brings you one option not this
guy two options watch one this one guess
what